Laute Telefone, ein kleines Kind, das schreit. Ich sitze in der Bahn, auf meinem Platz im Ruheabteil. Ganz egal in alles, was ich tu. Airports in die Ohren, ich hör euch zu. Florenzin und Stefan nun, V, hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu hu oder man merkt, der Film, den man gerade angefangen hat, ist sehr gut. Dann hat man dieses symboliger Schauer durchfährt einen. Das habe ich jetzt auch. Es ist herrlich, man fühlt sich direkt zu Hause. Vielen, vielen Dank an Kolja und Jair. Die haben schon mal ein Intro eingereicht, das war auch schon fantastisch. Aber das hast du abgelehnt. Man muss ja auch sagen, vorhin ist es knallhart. Ja, ja. Es darf nicht so gut sein, weil dann erwartet man irgendwie eine krasse Folge, die kommt dann natürlich ob nicht nicht. Da darf man nicht so schlecht sein, weil es sollte ja immer noch Leute anlocken. Aber das ist natürlich interessant. Und ich finde, Kolja und Jair haben wahrscheinlich genau perfekt getroffen, der eine ist zu gut, der andere ist zu schlecht. Und zusammen finden sie genau dieses herrliche Mittelmaß, das wunderbar funktioniert, für mich zumindest. Ich muss diese Frage stellen als Journalist, wer ist denn der Gute und wer der Schlechte? Ja, das ist jetzt natürlich die Frage. Das ist natürlich das Schwierige, aber ich sage mal, wir wissen beide, in welche Richtung es geht.
Das habe ich mir schon gedacht, ich will es nur gerne von Ihnen hören.
Stefan Tietze ist der Name des Menschen, den ihr hier investigativ fragend hört. Das ist sein Name.
Und der, den ihr jetzt hier gerade beschreibend gehört habt, das ist Florentin Will. Der ist dann tatsächlich auch wieder dabei.
Wer hier gerade einen Grund benutzend zu hören war, das war Stefan Tietze an der Stelle.
Der, der gar nicht weiß, was das bedeutet an dieser Stelle, wenn es einfach mal gesagt hat, es war auch Stefan Tietze.
Herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid bei einer neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast Uwo, Folge 357.
Folge 357, eine Primzahl?
Jo, nehme ich.
320.
Ach Gott, Viel Spaß.
Viel Spaß.
Der Rest der Folge ist einfach 3,1, 4, 5, nee, 2.
Rechne mal einmal durch sieben.
Nee, wir müssen heute, glaube ich, ein bisschen was abarbeiten.
Heute wird eine Redaktionsfolge, redaktionelle Folge, wir müssen heute wieder so ein bisschen abarbeiten, denn es ist einiges wieder aufgelaufen, hat sich aufgestaut und das muss jetzt weggearbeitet werden.
Heute wird weggearbeitet.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, was es zu Wegarbeiten gibt, weil wie immer kann ich mich nicht erinnern an die letzten 50 Folgen, aber bin ganz gespannt, was da kommt. Ich bin erholt, ich bin ehrlich gesagt Vitamin D, Tank ist wieder voll, mir geht es richtig gut. Sehr gut. Ich habe das Gefühl, die Sonne kommt raus und Stefan wird wieder zum Sonnenschein. Diese Scheissdrecks, fickt euch, Januar, Februar, März, Monate sind jetzt auch immer langsam vorbei, wettertechnisch hinter uns gelassen, jetzt wirklich, also ich bin Sommerkind. Du gehst in die Sonne und dann versuchst du auch möglichst viel Haut der Sonne entgegenzustrecken, dich wirklich so wie so eine Solarzelle aufzubauen? Nee. Ich habe tatsächlich meine Wohnung in Berlin, die so in den Hinterhöfen verkeilt war, dass man nur für einen ganz kurzen Moment, nur für so wirklich 60 Sekunden Sonne hatte.
In der Zeit hast du dir die Rollerbeamme zugemacht, wütend.
Bis ich irgendwann gehört habe, das ist nicht so gut, du brauchst die Sonne tatsächlich,
wie so eine kleine Sonnenblume, und damit der Kopf nicht hängt, braucht man auch ein bisschen Sonne. Hat der Arzt das dir so erklärt, du sollst nicht zu Kinderärzten gehen, habe ich dir schon mal gesagt.
Aber da kriege ich erstens mal einen Lolli, und zweitens habe ich auch das Gefühl,
die verstehen meine Probleme ein bisschen besser.
Du hast zwei Dinge gesagt, die wirklich für Kinderärzte sprechen, auch als Erwachsener sollte man da hingehen. So redet übrigens mein Steuerberater mit mir. Der malt immer, das ist kein Witz, Strichmännchen auf und erklärt mir dann, wie das läuft. Und ich denk mir, dass ich derjenige bin. Also er braucht, vor allem visualisier nicht mich als Menschen, als Strichmännchen, sondern visualisier den Rest. Also ich bin gar nicht gegen diese, verstehe mich nicht falsch, gegen diese abstrakte Zeichnung, um mir Dinge zu erklären. Ich verstehe nur nicht, warum man da anfängt mit mir als Strichmännchen. Mach das weg, mach mein Portemonnaie als, als, warum meine Finanzen. Das ist Vater Staat, der mit dem langen Bart. Okay. Der hält die Hand auf.
Sehe ich.
Okay, was machst du? High five?
Nein, ich gebe ihm ein Teil von meinem Geld, was ich bekomme.
Wunderbar. Letztens hatte ich ein Problem, weil wir hatten diese Frage schon mal Steuer und Absetzen.
Und was bedeutet Absetzen? Das ist so ein Wort. Das ist jetzt auch erst mal nur da.
Nee, das weiß ich nicht.
So, und dann habe ich letztens überlegt, fuck, was war Absetzen nochmal? und dann habe ich mich an eine Situation erinnert, wo ich dir das erklärt habe. Und ich dachte mir, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, dass ich irgendwann mal an dem Punkt war, wo ich es jemand anderem erklären konnte, und ich es jetzt selber nicht mehr weiß. Also, jetzt erklärst du es dir erklären. Wir haben immer so ein schlechtes Gedächtnis, dass man sich Wissen immer hin und her wie so ein Pingpong, und vor allem, ich denke mir, wenn ich es erklärt habe, dann ist es auch weg in gewisser Weise. Für alle nochmal, komm, für alle nochmal. Wir wiederholen alle nochmal kurz die Steuerklasse A1. Erste Kurs, wir kommen erstmal rein, stellen uns alle vor. Können wir nicht wieder Ephigenie machen? Können wir nicht wieder Ephigenie machen, Herr Tietze? Also, wir zahlen, wir kriegen alle Geld und zahlen auf dieses Geld, das ist nicht ganz unser Geld, das ist die Bruttoeinnahmen, darauf zahlen wir Steuern, was über die Nettoeinnahmen. Auf alle Sachen, die wir an Steuern zahlen, gibt es aber gewisse Beträge, das kann man absetzen. Wenn wir zum Beispiel als Podcaster Mikros kaufen, dann sind das Arbeitsgeräte, die kann man absetzen. Ja, aber ich habe ja hier auch mein Rap-Album aufgenommen. Richtig. Das hat ja noch kein Geld eingespielt, leider. Du bist, schaut mal vorbei auf Bandcamp. Ja, das wird auch wahrscheinlich nicht mehr. Easy Flow. Easy Flow? Easy Flow. Ich habe einen Kumpel von mir, das dürft ihr nicht klauen, will sich, das hat eine Rap-Strasse. Wenn man sagt, das darfst du aber nicht klauen. So heißt das Album auch, bitte nicht klauen. Bitte nicht klauen. Und er hat sich den Rap-Namen überlegt, Panther Ray. Okay. Und Panther Ray ist ja das alte Gesetz, das alte, ich weiß nicht, physikalische Gesetz, alles fließt. Und Everything Flows ist es auf Englisch. Ach so. Und Everything Flows, Panther Ray ist ja wohl der beste Fall. Ist richtig gut, aber dann auch als Panther. Ja, natürlich. Also ein Panther ist auf dem Albumcover dann drauf. Natürlich ist, ich habe das auch schon mal gemacht, auch Spaß, weil ich da so Fan von war, von der ganzen Idee. Also vielleicht klaue ich das einfach. Aber was, wie viel Druck auf deinem Freund liegt, das Albumcover steht schon, alles ist schon da, die Tour ist quasi geplant, nur es gibt halt noch keine Songs. Aber weder ist er ein grosser Rap-Fan, noch stehen viele Songs.
Ein paar Songs, die sind ähnlich genial vom Titel her.
Also konzeptionell, es ist ein Konzept-Artist.
Vor allem, ihr könntet ja eine Kollabo machen und die Fanta Ray nennen.
Fanta Ray, ja, finde ich sehr gut.
Wenn du dabei bist.
Fanta-TM-Ray.
Hältst du noch fest an deinem Rappernamen Fanta?
Nein, habe ich da noch nie wirklich hintergestanden.
Was auch, glaube ich, daran liegt, dass er nicht durch Decke gegangen ist. Ja, ich bin Easy Flow. Wie kam das drauf? Du wolltest ein Rap-Einbogen? Also weil ich das Mikrofon ja auch als Rap benutze quasi. Du kannst deine ... Was ist mit meinem Drip? Du kannst deine Nike Airs, deine Air Jordans ... Was ist mit meiner Brilli-Kette? Du kannst alles ... Was sind mit meinen Brillis? Ist alles Arbeitsoutfit. Mit meinen Steinen. Weißt du? Das ist eine Uniform, eine Arbeitsuniform. Ja, Mechaniker zum Beispiel, Mechatroniker brauchen Blaumänner. Du brauchst Goldkette, Drip, Goldzähne, Geldzahn und deine Baggy Pants. Die kannst du alle absetzen, die kannst du gegen die Steuern rechnen, die du bezahlst. Anteilig. Und das ist absetzen. Ich habe ich noch mal ein Wort reingeworfen. Gut, anteilig. Geingehend anteilig. Nichtsdestotrotz musst du natürlich angemessenerweise auch gucken, dass da nichts falsch läuft. Ich kann immer meine Fahrtkosten absetzen. Und jetzt habe ich auch mal meine... Ich habe das Problem, dass ich so viel Strafen zahlen muss, dass ich immer so viel Parkstrafen zahlen muss. Kann man Gefängnisstrafen absetzen? Weil ich so dumm bin, weil ich meinen Fehler gemacht habe und den leider monatelang gemacht habe, jede Woche. Und deswegen kriege ich rückwirkend jetzt jede Woche. Und es läuft auch noch an. Ich kriege jede Woche. Und mittlerweile ist es zur Gewohnheit geworden. Und ich habe jetzt versucht, das abzusetzen. Und weiß nicht, ob das geht, weil wenn du mit deinem Betriebsauto geblitzt wirst, das ist ja Teil der, du wolltest ja schnell zur Arbeit, du wolltest ja ganz viel arbeiten, ganz schnell. Und dann kann man ja sagen, ja gut, das ist Teil meines, das ist halt eine erwartbare Gefahr, dass man einmal im Jahr geblitzt wird, kann man das absetzen. Ich schicke das, ich versuche das immer so. Das ist auch mein Schacht, schick mal erstmal alles hin. Erstmal hinschicken und vor allem unbeschriftet. Da denke ich mir sehr, die finden das, wenn sie es finden wollen, wenn nicht, dann nicht. Ich weiß auch nicht, wer die sind. Ob das überhaupt jemand anschaut. Ich habe gedacht, die einzige Möglichkeit, wo ich das sehe, vielleicht ist, als Joko und Klaas mal dieses Werds so oft geblitzt in der nächsten Stunde, wie es irgendwie geht, Szenario gespielt haben. Und da kann ich mir vorstellen, weil das ja wirklich Teil des Sketches ist, dass man da so dreist sein kann und die einreichen kann. Okay, und wenn du jetzt sagst, Coco und Klaas sind unterwegs und fliegen und Bungee-Sprung? Easy Flow. Bungee-Sprung? Easy Flow und Panther Ray sind unterwegs und machen die besten Bungee-Sprünge. Das war wahrscheinlich der einzige Grund, warum man diese Sendung macht und aus dem Flugzeug springt, wenn man es alles absetzen kann. Anteilig, natürlich, Leute, bitte rastet mich aus. Bitte, bitte nicht aus. Natürlich kann man das nur anteilig absetzen. Ich sehe schon oben diese rote Zahl bei Instagram und auf die ich schon gar keinen Bock habe. Deswegen Sternchen, anteilig, okay? Nicht, dass ihr mir alle ausflippt sonntags morgens. Das sind ja auch so diese Kritikimmunitätswörter, so in gewisser Weise, zum Teil. Ich denke, irgendwann können wir das ... Ich habe keine Ahnung, wovon ich spreche. Genau, hat man mir gesagt, so sagt man. Ich habe doch keine Ahnung von nichts. Ich lüge den ganzen Tag, um schlau zu wirken. Solche Dinge, die man dann mal reinwerfen kann in so ein Gespräch, wo eigentlich keine Kritik mehr kommen sollte, kommt aber. Genau, okay, das heißt, du bist jetzt am Absetzen fleißig, schickst Strafzettel ein, ich bin gespannt. Ja, was aber tatsächlich auch oft eingeschickt wird, sind Korrekturen von alten Dingen, die wir besprochen haben, und zwar, vielleicht kannst du nochmal zusammenfassen, was hat es mit der Taube auf sich? Also, wir haben gegoogelt, die Taube und haben dann die Friedenstaube gefunden bei Wikipedia. Und da stand drin, dass die Taube eigentlich gar nicht den Titel Friedenstaube verdient hat, weil die Taube jährlich, und jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr genau, jetzt kommt hier der Disclaimer, da bin ich rechtlich nicht verklagt werden kann, ist für sehr viele Morde verantwortlich. Wow, langsam, langsam, langsam. Wikipedia hat nicht... Kämp genau, Kämpfe für. Kämpfe kämpfen. Genau, das ist aber ein Unterschied. Es hiess, eine Taube ist jedes Jahr in 2000 Kämpfe verwickelt. Diese konkrete und sehr hohe Zahl hat uns dann doch stutzig gemacht. Wir wollten die Autoren zur Rede stellen, sie verwies an eine anonyme Institution, die weder Rang noch Namen noch Hand hat, die man drücken kann. Planet Wissen. Und Planet Wissen schweigt sich tot. Planet Wissen, ohrenbetäubendes Schweigen. Zu deren Verteidigung heissen sie nicht Planet Schreien, sondern Planet Wissen. Das stimmt. Und Wissen heisst nicht, wer schlaues schweigt. Und Planeten ist silber, Schweigen ist goldig. Und Planeten sind da häufig, ist da keine Atmosphäre, da kann man gar nichts sagen.
Im Weltall hört man dich nicht schreien.
Jetzt hat sich allerdings auf Reddit, ich weiß nicht, ob er einen Doktortitel hat, Dr. BK-2CB gemeldet und er meinte, er hätte die Quelle gefunden. Und zwar geht das zurück auf Haag D. Haag Wackernagel, der im Jahre 1994 Anno Domini in dem Magazin Tierärztliche Praxis veröffentlicht hat. Er hat mich verloren. Der schreibt auf Seite fünf des PDFs, Jesus Christus. 1994 hat er schon PDFs rausgeworden, ein Strassentäuber. What is happening? Zwei Tauben, ein Täuber. Haben sich für dich die letzten fünf Minuten auch wie so ein Fiebertraum angefühlt, weil ich weiß nicht mehr, was war es. Ein Täuber ist eine männliche Taube. Ah, wie das Trutun. Wie das Trutun oder der Erpel gibt es den Täuber. Immer Vögel. Es ist so weird. Das Trut, der Trutan, das war auch schon so fucking weird. Ja, ist bei Vögeln eher der normale Name weiblich? Du sagst Ente? Nee, der Trutan. Eben nicht. Bei den zwei Beispielen, die wir haben, ist 50. Ja, aber Ente ist die weibliche Form die normale, bei Katze auch. Und dann Erpel, Möwe, der Möwer. Die Möwe, der Möwerus.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Aber auf jeden Fall schreibt Dehaag Wackernagel, schreibt, ein Strassentäuber hat in seinem Leben schätzungsweise 5000 Kämpfe durchzustehen. Also hier geht es um die 5000. Und zwar ist das so, wir müssen uns natürlich die wissenschaftliche Methode anschauen. Und zwar heißt es, 50 Tauben über zwei Jahre wurden insgesamt 120 Stunden mit einer Videokamera gefilmt. Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? 50 Tauben über zwei Jahre, 120 Stunden.
So, jetzt kann ich aber zum Beispiel, kann ich das absetzen.
Kann ich 20 Stunden absetzen.
Also die Stunden, die du nicht gefilmt hast, kannst du absetzen.
Aber die, die du gefilmt hast, nicht.
So, und dann hat man die 120 Stunden genommen, gezählt, wie oft kämpfen die einzelnen Tauben miteinander.
Gut, da muss man auch Definitionen aufstellen für Kämpfen.
Was ist Kämpfen? Und vor allem zählt der Kampf für beide? Aber so, du kannst nicht von meiner Nase langfliegen, bitte nicht. So was ist ja kein Kampf. Wenn ich dich jetzt picke, ist das ein Kampf für uns beide oder nur für mich? Alles unklar. Alles unklar, Haag, Wackernagel sagt dazu gar nichts und letzten Endes heißt es, dass das die Methode war, mit der man letzten Endes dann auf die 2000 kam. Also die Idee war, Tauben werden 2,4 Jahre alt und haben 5000 Kämpfe, also pro Jahr 2000 Kämpfe. Also das geht dann gut auf, das ist doch schön. Das gleiche schreibt uns übrigens auch Julia. Julia hat uns geschrieben, dass sie auch die Quelle gefunden hat von Professor Doktor Daniel Haag-Wackernagel und der hat zwei Jahre lang Tauben erforscht und zwar kann man darüber auch hören in der aktuellen Folge von Fakt Up. Ah, okay, vielleicht hören die das Podcast so. Fakt ab, ab Minute zwölf, neunundzwanzig könnt ihr mehr über diese Taubenexperimente und Professor Doktor Daniel Haag-Wacker-Nagel hören. Aber darauf basiert das? Viel Spaß damit und danke für Julia. Ja. Also ich finde das nämlich weird. Können wir das mal kurz kopieren, diesen Reddit-Eintrag? Vielen Dank an BK2CB. Können wir das nicht an unsere liebe Frau Autorin schicken und sagen, ist das deine Quelle? Auch direkt duzen, um so eine gewisse Augenhöhe auszulösen. Ich weiß nicht, wo wir jetzt noch mal bei Planet Wissen stehen, ob das sozusagen Vertrauensbruch ist Planet Wissen gegenüber. Ich finde das eine sehr, sehr fragwürdige Methode. Es ist eine super fragwürdige Methode. Was heißt Kampf 5000? Aber es muss ja in der PDF stehen. Wer zählt denn bis 5000? Was ist die höchste Zahl, auf die du jemals gezählt hast? Vier. Wer? Was ist die höchste Zahl, von der du jemals runtergezählt hast? Zehn, Silvester. Oh, starker Sprung. Aber wirklich interessant, weil, also ich finde das alles auch, diese Formel finde ich alles merkwürdig. Dann ist da jemand mit einer Kamera hinterher gelaufen und macht das vielleicht einfach die Tauben aggressiv? So ein RTL-Reporter, der einfach so aufdrückt, so, was sagen Sie, Herr Tauber, was sagen Sie, Herr Tauber? Und die läuft so weg. Kämpfe vor allem gegen den Reporter selbst. Nee, die haben den Schlag gefilmt, was erst schon mal ein sehr gewaltsamer Name ist. Also wenn dein Haus schon Schlag heisst, sorry. Aber wer mit Gewalt aufwächst, wird und bleibt gewalttätig. Das sage ich immer. Das habe ich mir so oft gesagt. Wenn man den Schlag aufwächst, dann bist du einfach so eine Kriegstaube. Wenn du im Täuberschlag zu Hause bist, dann gibt es auf jeden Fall Schwierigkeiten. Wollen wir den Schlag umbenennen in Friede? Finde ich sehr gut. Finde ich schön. Frieda? Ja. Und dann mal gucken. Dann gucken wir, wie viel die Kämpfe runtergehen. Naja, es sind auf jeden Fall Daten. 1.800 nur noch Kämpfe. Es sind vor allem auch Daten aus den frühen 90ern. Also da wurde seitdem absolutes Forschungsbrachland leider. Also ich bin nicht zufrieden mit der Methodik, nicht zufrieden mit der Erklärung, nicht zufrieden mit der Analyse und die Formel verstehe ich auch nicht so ganz, aber das mag an mir liegen. Aber das ist also der Grund, warum bei der geneigten, gesegneten Taube im Wikipedia-Artikel steht, sie hat den Namen Friedenstraube nicht verdient. Rbe, genau. Und deswegen möchte ich jetzt in diesen Artikel gehen und ich werde den jetzt korrigieren. Moment, was sagst du, warum? Weil ich finde die Forschung unzureichend. Ich finde die Methodik zumindest lückenhaft. Dann schreib anteilsweise dazu, dass das schon, also du möchtest jetzt die Friedenstaube, den Ruf der Friedenstaube, du musst den Ruf der Taube retten, indem du sagst, die ist gar nicht in so viel Kämpfe entwickelt, weil die Methodik fehlerhaft ist. Fehlerhaft. Ich schreibe jetzt hier rein. Das Symbol der Friedenstaube genau, es geht ja nur um diesen einen Satz, damit wir ganz kurz hier nicht jetzt wegsprinten. Aber der Satz ist schön. Das Symbol der Friedenstaube hat in der Strassentaube, die in schätzungsweise 2000 Kämpfe im Jahr verwickelt ist, keine verhaltensbiologische Entsprechung. Aber hast du gehört? Schätzungsweise. Schätzungsweise. Und da hieß es auch, dass Schätzungsweise auch ein wissenschaftlicher Begriff ist, der nämlich gewisse Parameter erfüllen muss, damit man schätzungsweise sagen darf.
Du darfst nicht einfach irgendwas sagen und dann einfach schätzungsweise davor klatschen, so wie ich das schätzungsweise jeden Tag mache. Aber in der Wissenschaft kannst du das nicht einfach so machen, denn in der Wissenschaft hat jedes Wort eine Bedeutung. Ja, das auch. Gut, ich würde dir diesen Satz, ist die Frage, oder wollen wir, das finde ich die passivere Variante jetzt, in diesen Diskussionsbeitrag, den es ja oben immer gibt bei Wikipedia. Ja, ich schreib das mal, finde ich gut. Ich kann da nicht reinschalten. Es hieß aber, dass die Quelle verbessert wurde auf dem Wikipedia-Artikel von Taube. Also der Reddit-Poster hat das glaube, auch schon angenommen. Also da sind die wissenschaftlichen Mühlen tatsächlich schon am Rotieren.
Ich glaube, da müssen wir selber gar nicht mehr die Hand reinhalten, Stefan.
Überlass das mal lieber Leuten, die zumindest einen Wikipedia-Account haben und da jetzt nicht irgendwie als Gast, als Invitizioso,
irgendwie anfangen, da rumzueditieren, was am Ende eh gelöscht wird.
Stefan?
Das Symbol der Friedenstaube hat in der Strassentaube,
das schreibe ich in den Diskussionsbeiträg jetzt, Satz in der Einleitung, schreibe drunter, die Quelle.
Ich habe nur Angst, dass dieser schöne Satz irgendwann rausfällt.
Zugegebenermaßen schreibe ich auch. Sehr schönen Satz ist zumindest fragwürdig. Auch eine nähere Recherche lässt diese Zahl nicht ... So, jetzt hab ich mich in einem Sprachseil. Zweifelsfrei bestätigt. Zweifelsfrei ... Zweifelsbrei habe ich ausser dem geschrieben. Bestätigen. Noch mal auf die letzten Wörter noch mal gestolpert. Ja, ein bisschen Zweifel bleibt immer in der Wissenschaft. Du kannst das nie hundertprozentig wissen. Der Studie ist ebenfalls zu hinterfragen. Wollen wir wollen wir uns morgen um 13 Uhr pass auf, wir treffen uns morgen um 13 Uhr. Zu welcher Zeit? Was haltet ihr für morgen um 15 Uhr im Kaffee Atlantik? Tettatett. Lass uns das morgen 16 Uhr Kaffee Atlantik klären. Aber der Kellner ist ein bisschen unhöflich. Ihr erkennt meinen Absatz gut an den zu vielen Absätzen. Also wenn ihr jetzt auf die Diskussion geht, wird der Friedenstaube, puh, da bin ich jetzt ein bisschen ... Man sieht, dass da jemand keine Ahnung, was er tut. Aber ich würde es erst mal so stehen lassen, dann sollen Leute, die da mehr Ahnung haben. Zweiter redaktioneller Punkt, der abgehakt werden muss heute, und zwar das Thema Hotpot. Wir hatten es letzte Woche von Hotpot, ich wurde angeschrieben, ob ich Herr Stephan aus Berlin sei, der ein Hotpot-Level hat. Close, so close. Super close, deswegen dachte ich ja auch, dass ich hier vielleicht geködert werde. Schreibt mir tatsächlich jemand, exakt die gleiche Nachricht hat auch ein Kumpel von ihm bekommen. Das scheint also eine Art Scam zu sein. Spam-Scam. Jetzt kenne ich mich mit Spam-Scams nicht so gut aus. Aber welcher Spam verliert das Interesse? Weil ich habe ja irgendwann gesagt, welchen Level haben sie, welchen Level habe ich, weil die Frage war, welchen Level hat dieser Hotpot-Koch. Und irgendwann hat die Person gesagt, nein, sie sind nicht, Herr Stephan, und hat einfach aufgehört. Also normalerweise versuche ich ja, den anderen abzuwimmeln, wenn er ein Spam-Scammer ist, und hier war es andersrum. Ich wurde irgendwann einfach abgewimmelt und geghostet. Frage, geht es bei Spam-Scam nicht vor allem darum, herauszufinden, ob die Nummer richtig in Benutzung ist? Sehr gut. Sehr, sehr gut. Weil wenn das, und dann finde ich auch die Frage toll, weil die ist nicht so Spam-Scam-y, dass man darauf nicht antwortet, sondern wie du fühlt man sich dann auch irgendwie bewogen zu sagen, hey, bin ich nicht, alles gut. Sind Sie Herr Stephan aus Berlin, der Hotpot Level 3 hat? Aber warum würde man da noch weiter antworten, um zu gucken, wie dumm man ist? Das ist nämlich übrigens meine Theorie. Pass auf, ich krieg wahnsinnig viel Spam. Ich hab auch mein Leben dahingehend schon aufgegeben. Ich glaube nicht, dass ich aus diesem Spam-Sumfeld wieder rauskomme. Ich krieg unendlich viel Spam, und mittlerweile versuch ich da sogar ein bisschen System zu finden. Ich krieg wirklich locker 50 Mails, einfach Hardcore-Spam. In der Minute. In der Minute, ja. Aber du bist auch in sehr viel Strassenkämpfer unterwegs. Das stimmt. Und es gibt zwei Arten von Spam und ich sehe da System. Es gibt einmal die Spamsorten, die offensichtlich Spam sind, grottenschlecht und null glaubwürdig. Aber was wollen die? Wollen die eine Nummer? Pass auf, pass auf. Das ist nämlich meine Vermutung. Es gibt einmal die Spam-Mails, die, wie ich finde, absichtlich schlecht sind. Und zwar, da steht dann irgendwie Viagra mit Strichen und so, weil man die Buchstaben nicht schreiben kann wegen Spam-Erkennung. Alles furchtbar, krudes Deutsch, alles schlecht. Einerseits natürlich, um die richtig dummen Leute zu finden, aber ich glaube, das hat ein System, denn es gibt noch die zweite Art von Spam, die extrem professionell sind, die super professionell sind, wo dann irgendwie steht, von deiner Bank, habe ich letztens die Mail bekommen von meiner Bank, wo heisst, wir führen jetzt ein KI-Sicherheitssystem ein, das gegen Hacker schützen soll, wollen sie sich dafür anmelden, klicken sie auf den Button und danach bekommst du irgendwie Phishing-Seite oder so für deine Mail. Und die sind perfekt gemacht, Design. Und ich glaube, das gegen Hacker schützen soll, wollen sie sich dafür anmelden, klicken sie auf den Button. Und danach bekommst du irgendwie Phishing-Seite oder so für deine E-Mail. Und die sind perfekt gemacht, die seien. Und ich glaube, das ist nämlich diese Zwei-Phasen-Strategie, dass du sagst, ich bin jetzt ein Betrüger und die Hälfte meiner Spam sind grottenschlecht, so dass der User denkt, ja, das ist ja offensichtlich Spam, wer fällt denn auf so einen Scheiss raus, damit die Leute sich für Spam-resistent halten, damit die bei den echten, richtig guten Spam-Mails nicht mehr so stark überprüfen. Weil die denken, ich weiss ja, wie Spam aussieht. Spam ist super schäbig, Spam ist super schlecht. Man könnte einfach dagegen argumentieren auch, je weniger Spam es gibt, desto weniger Spam-resistent wollen Leute ja sein. Das heisst, wenn es die alten, schlechten Spams gar nicht gibt, dann wären die anderen ja nie entlarvt worden. Spam ist ja nur so gross Thema in Podcasts zum Beispiel oder bei uns jetzt gerade, weil es so viel gibt, weil es so ein großes Problem ist und so ein Thema ist. Und deswegen glaube ich, people look into it. Ich habe die Theorie, ich glaube, da stehen die gleichen Leute dahinter, weil es, ich glaube, es funktioniert bei mir gut. Weil wenn ich dann, also ich würde schon oft ausgenommen, und wenn ich dann so eine Mail von der Bank sehe, ich bin dann wirklich kurz davor zu denken, ach ja, gibt Sinn, KI hört man gerade so, die sind gut gemacht. Und ich glaube, man soll da so eingeweicht werden, dass man sich denkt, man ist zu schlau dafür. Ich habe eine Spam-Arroganz, eine gewisse. Ich glaube, mir wird das niemals passieren, dass ich darauf reinfalle. Und vielleicht ist mit ... Jetzt hast du aber gerade ... Ich glaube, mir geht eher Geld durch die Lachen. Jetzt hast du Anonymous auf dich aufmerksam gemacht. Mir geht eher ... Und jetzt wirst du einfach zugeballert und irgendjemand kriegt dich. Ich habe schon, glaube ich, ich mache auch gerne bei Gewinnspielen mit und sowas, da habe ich schon oft nicht darauf reagiert. Ja, lieblich. Vielleicht, obwohl ich gewonnen habe, einfach weil ich dachte, das ist vielleicht Spam. Keine Ahnung, aber ich gebe dir recht, es ist manchmal super merkwürdig, wie bescheuert schlecht die gemacht sind. Gar keine Mühe und dann auch sowas wie Viagra oder was auch immer, also ist ja auch, alles daran ist ja unseriös, auch so direkt mit Medikamenten zu kommen. Es wäre ja nur clever, also sowas wie Post, Bank und sowas, das ist ja alles clever, DHL, wir haben ein Paket für sie. Ja, die wollen nicht weich machen, ich glaube, das ist die Idee dahinter. Ich glaube, das ist die Idee dahinter. Mittlerweile habe ich auch mal recherchiert und habe geguckt, von welchen E-Mail-Adressen kommen eigentlich Spam-Mails. Und die kommen ja manchmal so von irgendwas super Strange, aber manchmal kommen sie auch einfach, ich habe viele gelöscht, aber manche kommen auch von wirklich normalen E-Mail-Adressen. Ja, zum Beispiel irgendwie dann so alfred at oldtimerfreunde.de oder sowas, oldtimerheaven.com. Frage, weil der gehackt wurde jetzt, weil sie seinen Server benutzen? Das ist die grosse Frage, weil irgendwo habe ich dann auch mal eine dieser Domains, also das, was nach dem Ad steht, habe ich dann mal eingegeben und das war so ein Kfz-Mechaniker aus den USA und der hatte auch eine E-Mail-Adresse und den konnte man kontaktieren und ich glaube, der weiß gar nicht, dass in seinem Namen sich der Parasiteer jemand da reingeschlichen hat und von seiner Domain da E-Mail schreibt. Oder er ist der smarteste Werber der Welt. Er hat halt nur diese kleine Autofarm in Oklahoma, aber er wundert sich, warum ganz viele Leute plötzlich auf der Matte stehen oder ihn anrufen und sagen sollen, er soll aufhören mit diesen Mails, oder aber er ist ein gewiefter Fuchs, ein Internetfuchs, der einfach Bock hat, das zu nutzen als modernes Medium,
damit Leute auf seine scheisse Website gehen.
Ich weiß noch nichts. Hier zum Beispiel habe ich die Mail bekommen,
hier finden sie Detailinformationen zu ihrer Sendung, abgeschickt von DHL.
Wenn man auf DHL draufklickt, merkt man es nicht
wirklich von DHL, sondern von Danny
at Asiancammodels.com,
was natürlich erst mal nicht unbedingt
vertrauenserwechend ist. Und er ist das beste Asiancammodel.
Danny, wirklich seit Jahren Megaleistung als als Asian Cam Model. Und ich habe überlegt, nur Recherchegründen bei Asiancammodels.com vorbeizuschauen und sagen, wisst ihr, dass eure E-Mail-Adresse in unlauteren Dingen verwickelt ist? Asiancammodels.com, hallo, Sie sprechen mit Sabine. Hallo, guten Tag, Florinchen hier. Hi. Und zwar, ich habe eine, wollte Ihnen, also, ich will gar nicht jetzt, also, weil ich habe überlegt. Hallo, sind Sie noch da? Ja, ich bin noch da. Ah, okay, Sie haben so gestockt. Ach so, okay. Und zwar, ich wollte Sie darauf hinweisen, dass Ihre Domain benutzt wird, um Spam-Mails zu verschicken. Alles klar. Mit wem haben Sie da Kontakt gehabt? Und zwar mit Danny. Danny, ah, Danny. Alles klar. Einen Moment, soll ich Sie verbinden? Ähm, was war das? Ich wollte eigentlich nur Bescheid sagen, aber ich, ja. Ich verbinde Sie, einen Moment. Hallo, hier ist Danny. Hi, Danny, du, ich habe eine Mail von dir bekommen, danny at asiancammodels.com. Genau, das ist meine E-Mail-Adresse. Genau, aber das ist Spam, glaube ich, also das ist eine DAL-Sendungsverfolgung, die gar nicht existiert. Nee, das soll nicht passieren. Nee, das soll gar nicht passieren. Kann ich das irgendwie wieder gut machen? Das weiss ich bei mir nicht, das musst du dir keine Sorgen machen, ich bin da recht Spam-resistent. Ich wollte nur dich darauf hinweisen, dass jemand deine E-Mail-Adresse benutzt, um Spam-Mails zu schicken. Ah, okay, ja, das ist mega uncool, ne? Ja, ja, da kann man einem wieder auf reinfallen, da können bestimmt bestimmte Sachen passieren. Ja, absolut. Das tut mir leid, also im Namen von, ich will auch unseren Ruf nicht schädigen, ich meine, Asian Cam-Models ist seit Jahren, wir bestreben uns um einen guten Ruf. Absolut, nein, und ich bin ja sonst auch völlig zufrieden mit Ihrem Angebot und ich finde, Sie liefern qualitativ hochwertige Produkte und wirklich absolut toll.
Die Kundenservices sind super, überraschend gut tatsächlich.
Überraschend gut und auch die Qualitätssicherung und Vorführungsentwicklung, wir treiben da wirklich viel voran und tun ordentlich was für die Cam.
Nee, toll, freut mich. Also, falls ich da weiterhelfen kann, ich kann euch die Mail schicken. Nicht auf den Button klicken. Ah, okay, nee, werde ich nicht machen. Genau. Alles klar, ja, super. Okay. Vielen, vielen Dank. Gibt es sonst noch was, wo wir dir bei helfen können, oder? Ja, macht ihr das noch mit den Kameras, oder? Ja, na klar, machen wir das noch mit den Kameras. Okay, dann also wo, wie kann ich da? Einfach auf AsianCamModels.com Ah, okay, cool. Und dann und dann oben auf Danny klicken. Ich habe jetzt Mittagspause gerade, aber so ab 17 Uhr würde ich wieder am Start sein. Dann sehen wir uns. Dann freue ich mich sehr auf dich. Jo. Mach's gut. Ciao. Ciao. Ciao. Und so ziehen sie die Loser, nämlich Geld aus der Tasche. Meinst du? Ja. Die da anrufen. Hast du gemerkt, wie Danny wollte, dass du eigentlich länger noch was erzählst? Weil jede Minute, ist das so, ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, kann ich jetzt theoretisch, weil RTL und diese ganzen Gewinnspiele oder sowas in Werbepausen von, sagen wir mal, wer wird Millionär oder sowas, verstehe ich nicht so ganz. Weil das ist ja eine Nummer, die rufst du an. Ich behaupte, was machen die damit, die Geld verdienen. Richtig, viele Leute rufen da an. Ich glaube, ja. Kann ich jetzt bei der Telekom sagen, meine Handynummer kostet sehr viel Geld für Leute? Kann ich jetzt sagen, meine Nummer kostet Geld? Ich hätte gerne keine 011-blablabla-Nummer, sondern eine 01379-Nummer. 090-Nummer. 0800-Nummer. Ich weiß es nicht, ob du da... Und ich ziehe halt allen Leuten, die mich erreichen wollen, aber nur ein bisschen, deswegen ist es ja nicht so wahnsinnig moralisch fragwürdig, nur so ein bisschen Geld aus der Tasche jeweils. So Mobilfunkpreise können abweichen. Ich stehe auch auf meiner Website, da steht meine Handynummer und darunter Mobilfunkpreise können abweichen. 0,90 Stefan. Ey, ähm, tu ich fand dich, ähm, keine Ahnung, ich fand das Gespräch eigentlich ganz cool hier auf der Party. Du, falls du, falls du dir mal schreiben willst oder so, ich kann dir ein paar Fotos von heute Abend schicken.
Was ist deine Nummer?
Fotos von heute Abend schicken?
Ja, keine Ahnung, einfach wenn du, je nachdem.
Mega.
Dann genau, einfach eine Nummer, kann ich sagen?
Ja, genau.
Sag mal.
Genau, ist 0800 Stefan.
Okay, 0800 Stefan.
Genau, also 7, 8, 3, 3, 2, 6. Nochmal bitte? 0800 und dann Stefan. Das ist welche Nummer? Naja, 7, 8, kannst du ja überlegen, 3, 3, 2, 6. Die von Ihnen gewählte Hofnummer ist nicht vergeben.
Oh.
Die ist noch nicht ganz aktiv.
Aber ich glaube, 0800 ist kostenlos tatsächlich. Ich meine, ich habe ja auch mal kurz im Coin Center gearbeitet. Ich glaube, 0800 darfst du gerade nicht sagen. Ich glaube, 090 gibt es nicht mehr, das war ja früher so die Nummer. Aber eigentlich keine schlechte Idee. Ich meine, gut, man wird kaum noch angerufen heutzutage, aber finde ich schon eine gute Sache. Naja, also ich finde diese Masche weird auch mit DHL. Ich glaube, dass verschiedene Server genutzt werden, also schlecht gesicherte Websites, deren Serverspace wird genutzt. Alfred Hübner aus, weiß nicht, irgendwo Mecklenburg-Vorpommern mit seiner Autowerkstatt, wird glaube ich nicht wissen, dass er dieses Famine verwendet. Ja, es ist so merkwürdig, weil man denkt ja, dass die einfach irgendwie dann Kauderwelsch oder so. Hier zum Beispiel habe ich eine Inkasso-Mail bekommen, und zwar von Digital Digital World Palermo, das ist schon mal ein genialer Name, Digital World Palermo at Fiebertel.com. Also auch da, warum nicht einfach Kauderwelsch irgendwie irgendwas, aber es ist Digital World Palermo, wo ich mir denke, Moment mal, in Casso Palermo ist es in der Meer, was ist denn nahlos, wie kam das denn? Aber einfach grossartig, dass da irgendwie irgendjemand klaut oder entführt E-Mail-Adressen. Parasitär zeigt man sich auf Mails, ich glaube, Server Space ist hier dieses große Wort, wovon wir alle Angst haben.
Ich spreche es an, ich spreche es an, was wir andenken.
Dass uns allen auf der Zunge liegt, dass uns allen auf der Zunge liegt.
Du sprichst es anteilsweise mal an gerade.
Server Space, es geht um Server Space.
Das ist ja das, ich glaube, wenn du eine große, weiß ich nicht, Farm, Rechnerfarm dir kaufst, wo du, weil Internet ist ja auch Rechenraum. Du entscheidest dich gerade den Weg zu gehen, du musst ihn nicht gehen. Aber du kletterst die Leiter. Doch, aber so was wie Amazon und Apple und so was, Facebook, die haben ja wahrscheinlich, zahlen die sehr viel Geld für ihre Server. Da ist ja viel Rechenkapazität, läuft darüber ja. Du kannst ja nicht, wenn du eine kleine Spam-illegale Drecksfirma bist, willst du ja nicht sehr viel... Illegale Drecksfirma hier, was kann ich für sie tun, guten Tag. Ja, hallo, ich habe eine Nachricht von Ihnen bekommen und es nervt langsam. Es sind immer diese DHL, sie wollen mich mal verarschen und so und neulich war sie wie meine Bank. Jetzt habe ich mir auf diesen Link geklickt. Ja, wissen Sie, als billige kleine Drecksfirma haben wir eben keine Möglichkeiten, ein ehrenhaftes Geschäftsmodell einzunehmen. Sondern? Ja, sondern Betrug.
So. Wir sind eine illegale kleine Drecksfirma
und wir haben halt einfach nur Scheisskonzepte
und wirklich Arschlöcher am Telefon.
Mehr können wir leider nicht leisten, tut mir leid.
Die Webseite ist auch so Bullet Points.
Scheisskonzepte, Kackteam,
fickt euch. Betrug.
Schreibt nicht, fickt euch.
Interessum
und dann einfach nur so ein großes GIF oder so was, so ein augenrollendes GIF. Ja, aber es ist schwierig. Aber es ist, ich habe manche, letztens, weil ich habe wegen DAL ein Riesenproblem gehabt, weil ich habe dringend auf eine DAL-Nachricht gewartet und habe halt nur diese DAL-Spam-Mails bekommen. Und irgendwann dachte ich, weil ich gehe einfach mal drauf, weil irgendwie kann ich vielleicht jemanden erreichen, aber es gibt so manche, ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst, aber so manche. Warum sind es immer solche Leute wie du übrigens, die Spam-Probleme haben? Nee, es sind immer Leute, die habe ich mal draufgeklickt. Das sind immer lustigerweise, kriegt ihr dieses, wenn man so ein großes Diagramm mit so einem Overlay in der Mitte, so ein Schnittmengen-Diagramm, wenn man das hätte, von Leuten, die sehr viel Spam bekommen und Leuten, die immer sagen, wie lustig sie interagiert haben mit Spam, die Schnittmenge ist ein Kreis. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und ich glaube, der Hauptgrund ist, dass ich meine E-Mail-Adresse schon so lange habe. Die habe ich wirklich schon seit der Kindheit und die ist einfach so verseucht, die hat das schon alles, die hat jede Krankheit, die
liegt wirklich im Sterben, die jedes Mal, wenn ich
mein E-Mail-Postfach aufmache,
sagt die E-Mail-Adresse, töte mich,
töte, bitte,
bitte, beende es, beende es
einfach, wirklich irgendwie lauter Parasiten
in den Augen haben sich die Würmer schon
reingearbeitet und schlürfen das Gehirn leer
und ihr, bringt es einfach zu Ende,
es ist einfach alles schon gar. Du stehst mit so einem Outfit, so einem luftdichtes Pandemie-Outfit hast du dann so an und blüht. Was ist die Post für heute? Kannst du mir noch kurz sagen, ich möchte noch das eine, ich habe noch einmal bei Facebook hier über diese Neur angerustet, einfach kurz, dass ich das Passwort ändern kann. Ich komme nie wieder rein. Ich muss Ihnen erst die 60 Nachrichten von Inkasso Palermo noch sagen. Aber das ist nämlich der Punkt. Es gibt einige Webseiten und auch Apps, wo ich weiß, wenn ich mich hier auslogge, dann komme ich nie wieder rein. Dann war es das. Dann ist einfach Ende. Ich darf mich hier nie wieder ausloggen. Egal was passiert, zum Beispiel, und ich bin ehrlich, das Podcast UFO E-Mail-Postfach. Wenn ich mich da einmal auslogge, ist es aus, das war's. Ich habe wirklich noch diese eine Chance. Und ich habe leider den Fehler gemacht, mich aus der DAL-App auszumelden, weil ich mich vertippt habe mit meinen fettigen Wurstfingern, und da merkt man erst mal, was man überhaupt hatte. Wenn du nicht mehr reinkommst, keine Ahnung. das stimmt. Deswegen, noch mal kurz der Aufruf an euch,
vielleicht suchen wir bald noch einen ITler,
eine ITlerin für unser
schönes Projekt, denn... Archäologen,
IT-Archäologen, der mal was so richtig
schräbt, der Florentin hilft und vor allem
mir Angst nimmt, denn wir suchen
jetzt unseren ersten Mitarbeiter,
unsere erste Mitarbeiterin, und
deswegen haben wir auch eine Mailadresse eingerichtet,
die existiert und die nicht so schnell wahrscheinlich von Spam überrollt wird, wahrscheinlich bis zu diesem Moment jetzt gerade, das heißt, jobs at podcast-ufo.fail, denn wir suchen für uns, das Podcast Ufo hat ganz, ganz grosse Pläne im Internet und dafür suchen wir euch, wenn ihr ein Editor oder eine Editorin seid, die sich mit Videoschnitt auskennen, dann suchen wir euch alle Infos dazu. Findet ihr auf Instagram. Einfach schreiben, dann an jobs.podcast-ufer.fail für alles weitere. Kontaktieren wir euch. Wenn ihr einen Spam schicken wollt, bitte nicht an diese Adresse. Dann nehmt die alte, nehmt Zentrale. Die ist einfach schon verloren. Ich war halt kurz abgelenkt, weil ich habe eine WhatsApp-Gruppe von Nachbarn, wo die ganzen Probleme im Haus immer so besprochen werden. Wo immer sich beschwert wird, wenn da ein Bananenblatt runterfällt und einfach mal alles komplett vibriert. Wie gestern ging über Twitter so rum plötzlich ein Knall. Es gab einen Riesenknall bei Bielefeld und da hat irgendwie so zwei Eurofighter haben über Bielefeld-Ecke die Schallmauer durchbrochen, was so einen riesen Knall geführt hat. Aber das dachte ich auch, sowas wird dann auch besprochen.
Und zwar schreibt ein Nachbar, kurze Frage, unser Nachbar hinten raus hat sich einen Bewegungsmelder an den Teich gestellt, der den halben Tag Tiere imitiert.
Was? Ehrlich gesagt macht es seitdem wenig Spaß, Fenster und Türen zu öffnen, weil das Ding alle fünf Minuten losgeht. Bin ich da überempfindlich oder wie stark hört ihr das Geräusch? Was ich fantastisch finde, denn er hat einen Teich. Ich muss sagen, der Nachbar hinten raus hat so einen kleinen, so einen Town-Hausgarten, der vor allem aus einem Teich besteht, wo Keus drin sind. Ich glaube, er will nicht, es gibt auch Fischreihe, habe ich schon oft gesehen, dass Tiere kommen und den Teich leer picken. Und jetzt hat er sich überlegt, offenbar, ich habe es noch nicht mitbekommen, bei mir gab es noch keine Probleme, aber sich einen Bewegungsmelder an den Teichel, der den halben Tag lang Tiere imitiert. Also der Bewegungsmelder, der registriert den Angreifervogel und imitiert einen Panther. Du kommst jetzt durch meine Schranke, geh durch meine Schranke. Ah, okay. Und dann beim zweiten Mal, wahrscheinlich ist es ein Loop aus 15 verschiedenen Tieren. Ja, weil wenn der Tier sich daran gewöhnt hat, muss ein anderes Tier kommen. Ach ja, vielleicht auch ein Mensch. Hau ab du! Hey du! Pass auf du, geh ab, geh ab, geh auf, geh auf, du geh auf, du geh Bursche! Seitdem macht es wenig Spaß, die Fenster aufzumachen. Verstehe ich aber auf der anderen Seite auch. Aber das finde ich sehr gut. Aber wahrscheinlich eine gute Idee. Weil bei uns damals am Teich, in meiner Heimat, haben wir einfach auch Fischreiher. Da gibt es so Plastik, könnte man dann im Gartencenter kaufen. So einen anderthalb Meter grossen Fischreiher, könntest du dir aus Plastik kaufen und dann hinstellen. Das habe ich schon gesehen. Die Koi sind einfach fucking gefangen, die sind einfach verloren. Die müssen nicht Koi sein. Ja, aber in so einem Teich, das ist einfach wie so ein Buffet. Ich als Vogel würde da auch hingehen. Das ist einfach wie so in so einem Supermarkt, wo du so testweise, du kannst ja schon so fast diese Zahnstocher in die Fische stecken, die einfach nur so, ach da, nehm ich mir ein, wie so ein Tellerchen. Ja genau, wie die Restaurants in Boston, wo man sich so einen Lob Lobster aussuchen kann. Genau, wie die Restaurants in Boston. Völlig richtig, Stefan. Das ist genau der Vergeist. Na, aber da kann man sich im... Der lag mir genau auf der Zunge. Wieso denn, ist doch genau das Gleiche. Habe ich bei Family Guy doch gesehen. Da gibt es doch diesen Song sogar, da gibt es doch diesen großen, schönen, riesen Aquarien, wo drinnen die Lobster rumschwimmen, du kannst es auf einen zeigen, dann wird der einfach in Butter, in heiße Butter geworfen. Schrecklich, aber es ist genau das. Ja, mit einem Meer ins Zweite, ins Dritte. Erst Salzwasser, dann Süsswasser, dann Butter. Es wird immer heißer und Slash Butter. Es wird immer mehr Butter. Und am Ende bist du einfach ein toter Lobster in einem kochenden Buttertopf. Aber so ist es ein bisschen. Aber so muss es denn, müssen Tiergeräusche sein. Kann man da nicht irgendwas wählen, was irgendwie angenehmer fürs Ohr ist? Da irgendwie einfach mal so ein bisschen Musik oder einfach mal so ein Geräusch, das vielleicht Vögel hören, aber Menschen nicht. Das ist irgendwie so ganz hoch oder ganz tief, so dass Menschen gar nicht hören. Kann man da nicht irgendwie einen Kompromiss machen? Ich glaube, Vögel hören weniger als wir Menschen. Na, das glaube ich dann wieder doch nicht, weil die Kommunierenden darüber aber Geschrei. Ja, das stimmt, die müssen die Pfeifen auch hören. Vor allem ist es immer so geil, finde ich, dass Leute sich so eine Erholungsoase machen, der Teich, aber um den Teich zu verteidigen, muss man dann wieder so ein unglaublich nerviges, plärrendes Ding reinstellen, um den Erholungseffekt wieder komplett kaputt zu machen. Wie damals. Es kürzt sich alles immer wieder raus. Du hast so einen Flecken Land, einen schicken Landfleck, und dann kommen aber die anderen verfeindeten Landflecke an und wollen dir deinen Landfleck wegnehmen. Also wäre es nicht besser, gar keinen Landfleck gehabt zu haben. Das ist die eine Möglichkeit, und die andere Möglichkeit ist, du baust einen riesengrossen Steinwall da drum und dann so Burgen mit Schiesscharten, um deinen Landfleck zu verteidigen. Aber am Ende geht es nicht mehr von deinem schönen Landfleck, sondern von der Burg. Weil du brauchst die Burg, um das zu verteidigen. Und so funktionieren Garten auch. Deutsche Kleingärten funktionieren nämlich so. Im Grunde schon. Du hast ein kleines Fleckchen, dann kommt erst mal der Zaun drum. Und dann musst du den verteidigen mit Plastikstatuen von so Burgenschützen, Reiern, die die anderen verteidigen. Und was ich auch gesehen habe, ist so ein Disco-Kugel-artartiges ding was du dann in den teich schmeißt was nicht nur arg scheiße aussieht und dann auch einfach so das licht reflektiert und dann ab und zu so blendenden scheinen auf dich wirft und auf die tiere die sich da hinsetzen wollen um die es ist ein schlachtfeld es ist wirklich ein schlachtfeld ich habe es gibt eine tolle doku überühner beim Bayerischen Rundfunk, die sich einfach Familien begleiten, die Hühner haben.
Picken die mehr oder weniger andere Artgenossen? Die picken richtig hart. Ja, ja, die picken richtig hart. Und das ist einfach wirklich albern, weil du denkst dir, das ist so viel Aufwand und so viel Arbeit, weil dann beschwert sich der Nachbar, dass der Hahn so laut kräht. Und dann geht er zum Amt und sagt, das ist Ruhestörung. Und dann schickt das Amt einen Sachverständigen, der da ankommt mit einem riesigen Mikrofon, das er aufstellt im Garten, der genau seine Werte hat, so laut darf der Hahn krähen oder nicht. Aber dann, wenn der Sachverständige im Garten ist, dann kräht der Hahn nicht, weil das ist eine andere Situation und das ist vielleicht peinlich. Und der Sachverständige darf auch nicht weggehen, weil jetzt der Besitzer kommt und das Mikrofon in so eine Schallkammer stellt. Und die Besitzer, die haben natürlich jetzt ein Interesse daran, dass der Hahn nicht kräht. Das heißt, die versuchen jetzt möglichst den Hahn irgendwie zu beschäftigen, abzulenken, dass der Hahn nicht kräht. Und dann kräht er nicht. Und dann stehst du als Sachverständiger in so einem Garten von Leuten, die dich hassen, für die du der Feind bist, mit einem riesigen NASA-Mikrofon. und dann kht der aber nicht, dann stehst du da stundenlang rum und es ist alles eine solche Zeitverschwendung, wo er einfach denkt, warum müsst ihr den fucking Hahn haben am Ende und ich bin auf der Seite des Nachbarns, ich bin voll auf der Seite des Nachbarns. Und dieses unglaublich Clusterfuck-artige Ding, was da passiert, gesellschaftlich, dass man dann ein bisschen Sachverständigen holt, der einfach Stille aufnimmt, weil die Leute den Haaren ablenken, das guckst du dir dann an. Das gucke ich mir an und denke mir, ich will auch so ein Mikrofon haben. Ich will, dass wenn ich im Ruheabteil sitze, will ich mein Mikrofon aufstellen. Oh spannend, Dezibelgrenze. Immer wenn der Dezibel zu hoch ist, will ich sagen, Entschuldigung, hier Sie sehen, das ist leider über die Grenze, drüber, seien Sie bitte leise. Aber wollen wir das nicht machen wie der Teich? Wir verteidigen den Ruhrbereich wie den Teich. Nämlich immer, wenn es zu laut ist, ein ganz grelles Quietschgeräusch nur in die Richtung von der Person, die zu laut ist. Dann kommt dieses Geräusch, was jemand macht, wenn er so ein, immer ein anderes, so ein Nagel über die Tafel, diese Kreidetafel. Sehr gut. Das Geräusch kommt zum Beispiel, wenn eine gewisse Promillegrenze, dann auch. Das auch. Oder wie im Flugzeug, es fallen so Masken runter und da muss man dann dreimal einatmen und kurz schlafen. Weil der dreimal ist Chloroform. Weil man zu aufgeregt war. Immer so, du kannst ja, das fände ich auch immer geil, ich als Kapitän würde das im Flugzeug machen, wenn einer nervt, würde ich nur die Sauerstoffflasche nur bei einer Person runterfallen lassen. Einfach nur so, nur du bist jetzt gerade Notfall. Du bist einfach, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das technisch geht, ich hoffe es geht, nur eine Person und dann kriegst du Sympathie. Du bist wie ein Notfall. Ich habe mir gedacht, wann kommt das eigentlich, dass Anästhetiker so cool und machbar und ohne Backlashes usw. funktionieren, dass man einfach in ein Flugzeug steigt, weil du brauchst auch weniger Platz, wenn du einfach bewusstlos bist, dass man einfach, also, man braucht weniger, Moment, man braucht kein Komfort, man braucht kein Essen, du willst sagen, alle schlafen vor dem Flug ein und werden dann einfach so reingeworfen in die Gepäckluke und sind einfach alle aneinandergedrückt wie Sardinen und werden aufgeweckt. Herzlich willkommen bei Sleephansa. Herzlich willkommen, freut mich sehr, schön, dass Sie das testen. Ja, das ist nett, der Preis war wirklich günstig. Das weiß ich noch nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Kurz Spielstopp, Spielstopp. Weil Preis weiß ich nicht, irgendwie muss ich ja die ganze Asphäre haben. Also was soll ich sagen, was willst du, dass ich sage? Was bin ich für eine Figur? Ich bin Gerda Sömer. Wir kommentieren nicht den Preis. Okay, alles klar. Herzlich willkommen bei Sleephansa. Was kann ich mit dir tun? Oh, hallo, vielen Dank. Oh, das Essen war wirklich grossartig. Wie? Du hast kein, es gibt kein Essen. Okay, sorry, Entschuldigung, ich bin, nee, du bist Text, du steckst ein. Ich habe meine Figur noch nicht ganz verstanden. Okay, du bist... Ich bin Gerta Sünner und ich komme gerade an, aber ich habe ja schon ein Ticket gekauft. Du kommst nicht an, du reist jetzt gleich nach Gran Canaria. Okay, also habe ich ein Ticket gekauft. Du hast ein Ticket gekauft. Weißt du ja, wie viel es gekostet hat? Okay, aber ich möchte nicht, dass du noch, ich weiß noch nicht, wie teuer es wird. Ich weiß, wie viel es, aber erwähnt es einfach nicht. Okay, ist klar. Gut. Okay, hi, was kann ich für Sie tun? Hallo, ich würde gerne mein Gepäck abgeben. Ja, sehr gut. Ja, danke schön, danke schön. Genau, jetzt folgen Sie mir bitte. Sie kommen jetzt in den Einschlafraum. Ja. So, und jetzt, denken Sie an was Schönes? Ich habe hier schon mal irgendwie die Infusion.
Vor allem nach Gran Canaria, ne? Also da denke ich da, wie ich da am Strand sitze. Ja, denken Sie an die Sonne und an die All-Inclusive-Hotel wahrscheinlich. Und jetzt denken Sie an die Sonne und den tollen Strand und zehn bis von zehn runter langsam. Zehn. Und gute Nacht. So, und jetzt wird Frau Sünner
aus dem sonnigen Köln
wird jetzt nämlich
in so eine, wie man es jetzt kennt, aus
Japan-Hotels,
teilweise so kleine Cubicles,
so kleine Röhren,
sie kommt jetzt in so einen kleinen Sarg.
Das ist kleiner, als sich
hinzusetzen? Na klar.
Du kannst ja... Das wird nie so böse angeschaut. Na klar. Ja, wie viele Menschen passen denn? Ich dachte, du machst so wie Mikado, dass du die alle so aufrecht hinstellst, so Rücken an Rücken. Die kommen in so einen kleinen, also so maximal paar Zentimeter oben und unten, kommen die in so kleine Würstchen rein. Und dann wird das ganze Flugzeug bis unters Dach vollgestopft mit Christina. Aber warum brauchst du überhaupt diese Söhne? Schmeißt die Körper einfach aufeinander? Wenn die blaue Flecken haben, verklagen die mich der Hot. Die verklagen mich in Grund und Boden. Nein, die werden schon geschützt und wenn mal Turbulenzen auftreten oder sowas. Ich kann nur darauf jetzt auch, weil dieser Ryanair-Gründer will ja Stehplätze einführen. Ich meine, die kosten halt dann kaum was. Ja, wenn er bremst, fällst du um oder was? Genau, und es gibt aber auch keine großen Sicherheitsbedenken, weil er das nur auf Flügen erlauben will, wo das halt nicht passiert, sodass das Wetter vorhersehbar ist. Ja, aber wenn ich abstürze, dann habe ich ja einen Nachteil als Stehender. Ich glaube, du hast auch als Sitzender einen großen Nachteil, wenn du abstürzt. Okay, das wollte ich jetzt nicht hören. Übrigens, erste Klasse stirbt eher. Also nachweislich, weil das die Plätze immer vorne sind. Aber ist es nicht gut, schnell zu sterben in einem Absturz? Und sie werden auch schnell sterben. Jetzt genießen sie ihren Champagner. Aber ich finde das eigentlich gut. Nee, ich finde, du sprichst was Tolles an, weil ich finde ja natürlich, in unserer Gesellschaft hat sich schon seit Jahrtausenden etabliert, Essen und Trinken. Und schlafen. Essen und Trinken, schlafen, klar, aber ich glaube, ich muss mal aus. Du bist aus. Aber jetzt mal, das ist ganz klar, dass man, wenn man essen geht, dann kriegt man was Festes und was Flüssiges, klar. Wo ist Gasförmig? Wo ist denn der dritte Aggregatszustand? Warum hat sich es nicht genauso etabliert, dass man in der U-Bahn irgendwie holt seine Flasche raus, trinkst einen Schluck, warum nicht die Flasche, nimmst einfach einen Zug, Sauerstoff oder irgendwas Gutes für dich? Curveball, rauchen? Curveball abgewehrt, schädlich für dich, warum nicht was Positives? Curveball, Kräuterzigaretten?
Zweiter Curveball, Hust-Hust, okay. Naja gut, aber Gas in den Lungen ist ja generell Hust-Hust wahrscheinlich. Ja, aber ich verstehe nicht, warum kann man das nicht anbieten, weil ich meine, irgendwann, also die Wirtschaft muss wachsen, ist allen klar, jeder, der das unser Wirtschaftsteem verstanden hat, weiss, Wirtschaft muss wachsen. Und wir kommen irgendwann nicht mehr drum rum, den dritten Aggregatszustand als normales Verbrauchsgut
einfach einzuführen. Dass du zum
Supermarkt gehst und nicht nur einen Eistee
und irgendwie deine Dickmanns kaufst.
Der Grund ist Platz, weil es große Bälle sind.
Es sind große Gymnastikbälle.
Ja, oder du hast halt so Taucherflaschen,
so Taucherflaschen, wo du dann, oder wie so ein Airhorn,
aber du einfach so,
du trötest dir in den Mund.
So, Entschuldigung, so war ein Mund, ich habe einen ganz trockenen Mund, leider. Okay, dankeschön. Wir sind hier im Ruhrabteil. Wir sind hier im fucking Ruhrabteil. Was fällt Ihnen ein? Aber dass man einfach mal ein paar Züge nimmt. Aber vielleicht ist Rauchen genau der Punkt, dass der Mensch auch das Bedürfnis hat, Gas einzuatmen. Irgendwo in einem Land, ich weiß nicht, wo es war, Spanien oder so,
was irgendwas Südländisches da war, auf Kirmessen wurde dann,
ja, Märkten wurde dann so an diesen Ballons gezogen, weil die High machen.
Das war jetzt nicht, da war gar kein Helium drin, sondern was anderes,
ein anderes leichteres Gas als Luft, ich weiß es nicht.
Aber da wurde, und das sieht halt auch bescheuert aus. Ich verstehe auch, warum, weiß nicht, der Gaszustand nicht ein Thema ist. Ich finde das jedenfalls genial. Ganz billig fliegen, du kriegst nicht von dem Flug mit, du wie bei einer Vollnarkose, du wachst wieder auf, hast alles vergessen, dass jemals Zeit vergangen ist. Ja gut, aber was passiert, wenn du im falschen Körper aufwachst? Da hätte ich Angst. Nein, aber schau mal, stell mal, pass auf. Entschuldigung, wir fliegen übers Bermuda-Dreieck, nein, wir fliegen übers Bermuda-Dreieck, ich bin bewusstlos und am Ende wache ich im falschen Körper auf. Und dann musst du schauen, stopp, stopp, stopp, wer ist, wer gehört seinem Körper? Jeder findet sich mit dem zusammen, der den Körper hat. Und was ist, wenn die aber nicht hin und her gewechselt sind, sondern im Kreis, dass jeder quasi einen anderen hat. Einmal sind alle Körper durchgezogen. Wie so ein Sat-1-Film-Film, nur komplexer. Cool. Sat-1-Flug-Film-Film. Aber es ist keine schlechte Prämisse, dann haben alle einen anderen Körper und dann müssen die sich finden und wieder zurückfliegen. Vielleicht sowas wie Lost, nur halt mit unterschiedlichen Körpern. Ich fände das total gut. Ich verstehe nicht, warum man das nicht macht, weil es am Langfliegen, gut, wir reden jetzt auch, aber man spart auch Platz. Ich glaube, wir leben in einer scheiß Zeit, ich glaube, wir leben so hundert Jahre, bevor alles geile kommt, also dieses Einschlafschwierigkeiten, wie fucking lame ist das, das ist doch in fünfzig Jahren Jahren weg, in 50 Jahren gehst du ins Bett, dann hast du zwei Schalter, einen macht das Licht aus und den anderen drückst du drauf, du bist sofort geschlafen. Dein ist dein Schalter. Ja, dann machst du dich sofort auf, Licht aus, zack, bist sofort weg. Licht aus, Stefan aus. Ja, sofort weg und wir müssen da immer mit rumliegen und die Nachbarn sind wieder laut und draußen ist wieder, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, und du hast den Loop schon hundertmal gehört und du kannst nicht schlafen, das ist furchtbar. Ich glaube, das dauert noch ein paar Jahre. Achso, ich dachte, das wäre dein KI-Hund, den du dir geholt hast. In der nächsten Pandemie. So gibt es dann so KI-Hunde. K-9. K-9. K-9. Wir stellen KI-Hunde her. Wir sind nicht gegen KI. KI nein. Wir sagen nicht nein im Sinne von nein, wir sagen KI ja, aber mit KI nein. Wir sagen KI yes zu KI nein. Es ist ein Hund, der begleitet sie im Alltag. Sag es einfach englischer. Nein. Nein. Nein. KI nein. Nein. KI nein. Dann hilft es. Aber ich find das genial. Ich verstehe nicht, warum es nicht gemacht wird, weil du kannst auch die Flieger viel, viel voller machen. Du brauchst nicht mehr Komfort, du kannst diese blöden, das nimmt ja auch Treibstoff und so weg, diese dicken Sitze, die die da haben. Oder wir machen Flugzeuge, die nicht landen müssen. Essen. Du brauchst doch kein Essen mehr für Leute im Flugzeug. Warum ist es nicht Fliegzeug? Es gibt keinen guten Grund, warum. Aber warum vielleicht Flugzeuge, die nicht landen müssen. Essen, du brauchst doch kein Essen mehr für Leute im Flugzeug. Warum ist es nicht Flugzeug? Es gibt keinen guten Grund, warum.
Aber warum vielleicht Flugzeuge, die nicht landen müssen, sondern die sind in der Luft und du rennst ganz schnell mit so einer Leiter und springst dann rein oder sowas, während das Flugzeug fliegt und du musst gar nicht erst landen, weil beim Landen verbraucht dir das meiste Benzin.
Da habe ich eine gute Fangfrage für dich. Warum ist die Air Force One häufiger gestartet als gelandet? Das ist eine Fangfrage. Kleine Fangfrage. Oder eine Fangfrage. Okay. Warum ist sie häufiger gestartet als gelandet? Weil die immer in der Luft sein muss oder so und deswegen jetzt gerade in der Luft ist und deswegen einmal mehr abgeheben ist. Du denkst gerade, ist Airborne eine, ja, gute Frage, nein, eine gute Idee, aber es ist nicht der Grund. Die Air Force One, warum ist die wahrscheinlich häufiger gestartet als gelandet? Ah, andersrum wäre es leichter gewesen. Wieso? Warum ist die häufiger gestartet? Ich dachte, wenn sie erst in der Luft zur Air Force One geworden ist oder so. Nee, aber sehr gut. Weil die Alte kaputt gegangen ist in der Luft? Nee, es gab ein Amtsenthebungsverfahren, als die Air Force One gerade in Luft wurde. Da verliert sie sofort das Callsign. Und das war bei Nixon. Und deswegen ist sie gestartet als Air Force One noch und gelandet nicht mehr als Air Force One. Als was ist sie da gelandet? Als Airbus A? Als Brigitte, als unsinkbar fünf oder was war der Name? Vielleicht war es auch andersrum. Auf jeden Fall gab es ein, aber sie ändert, aber ist egal. Herr Jauch, ist das die richtige Antwort oder nicht? Sie können nicht sagen, vielleicht ist es auch andersrum. Ich meine gerade, vielleicht war es auch B. Naja, jetzt haben Sie, egal, jetzt haben Sie verloren, ähm, oder C, egal. So, dann kommt der nächste. Brigitte, Wahnsinn. Aber ich... Schöne Frage, ist eine nette Frage. Ist eine nette Frage, ich würde nur gerne wirklich wissen, ob es so oder andersrum war. Auf jeden Fall gab es ein Amtsenthebungsverfahren und entweder war Nixon gerade in der Luft und hat sein Amt verloren oder aber sein Nachfolger, der Vizepräsident, ist gerade in Luft gewesen und wurde zuvor zu Air Force One. Auf jeden Fall, entweder ist es häufiger gestattet oder häufiger gestattet. Ach so, oder wenn Kennedy erschossen wird, wird automatisch der Vizepräsident Präsident und der ist gerade in einem Linienflug von Ryanair steht gerade. Genau. Und damit wird automatisch dieses Flugzeug zu Air Force One, weil der Präsident in dem Moment sofort ist er im Urlaub und der Condor Flug 74 wird dann plötzlich zu Air Force One und direkt steigen nebenan so Eurofighter auf.
Ja spannend, toll, wahnsinnig interessant, dieses alles, dieses was jetzt, dieses alles halt, dieses alles, naja das was du halt gerade gesagt hast, wie wenig konkret war das denn? Ja, aber halt auch mit Trump und so. Habe ich gar nicht so gesagt. Wenn der jetzt der Prozess, wenn der jetzt im Gefängnis ist, wie soll das funktionieren? Dann mit die Zelle, die Air Force One. Im Grunde. Vor allem, der wird ja vom Secret Service beschützt als ehemaliger Präsident. Müssen die dann auch ins Gefängnis? Beschützen die den dann auch in der Zelle? Muss Amerika ins Gefängnis? Oder sind das dann Undercover-Leute?
Oder bildet man Häftlinge zu Secret-Service-Mitarbeitern aus?
Also wie macht man das logistisch?
Ja.
Also wie geht das?
Naja, kann man das einfach reinstellen.
Nochmal?
Man kann einfach Leute reinstellen, die vor die Gitter stehen.
In der Zelle?
Nicht in der Zelle.
Die auch dann im Gefängnis sein müssen.
Ja klar, davorstehen.
Die müssen auch nicht mit ihm ins Klo, wenn er aufs Klo geht, wahrscheinlich. Meinst du? Obama wird jetzt irgendwie von Klaas interviewt und geht auf so eine Stadion-Tour. Hallo? Weißt du, wer er ist? Ja gut, aber was sollst du denn machen als ... Weißt Barraco Barna, wer er ist? Weißt du, wer Coco Winterscheid überhaupt ist? Ich finde das so weird. Warum geht er auf Stadion-Tour? Er ist nicht fucking Bono, er ist Obama. Ja, aber ich glaube schon, also ich glaube, in dem Moment, in dem du nicht mehr Präsident bist, du hattest vor einer Stunde den fucking stressigsten Job der Welt, unfassbar viel Verantwortung und dann so, okay, danke, das war's und du so ja, schon Stadion-Toyles, ne? Tja, was haben wir noch heute, ach nee, ist ja morgen der Termin, ne? Du, Michel, brauchen wir noch was vom Supermarkt? Nee, und das sind solche Leute, die dann sagen, ah, draußen der Fischerei ja schon wieder. Genau, ich habe noch die Nummer von der Predator-Drone. Können wir die noch? Ich habe so ein Gerät gefunden. Das kann ich aufstellen, das macht Tiere nach. So jemand mit so viel Langeweile. Solche Leute stellen das dann auf. Ich ärgere mich jedenfalls, weil ich finde, er kann doch gut, man kann vielleicht kein Präsident mehr werden, wenn man die Amtszeit hinter sich hat. Wie lange muss man warten, bis man wieder kandidieren darf? Gibt's da so zehn Jahre, wo man rumsitzt? Karwemms-Mann-Zeit und dann geht er aber wieder.
Ich glaube vor allen Dingen, er könnte ja mal was anderes machen.
Also er könnte ja UN-Vorsitzender sein.
Das ist ja das Snowden-Problem.
Was macht Snowden?
Macht er jetzt einen Twitch-Kanal auf oder was?
Macht er ein Kochbuch oder wie?
Schreibt er ein Kinderbuch? Was macht Edward Snowden? Weiß macht Edward Snowden was machen diese Leute halt das ist immer das Ding du willst du denkst wie geil es ist Präsident zu sein aber was kommt danach was macht man nicht jetzt in der Supertalent Jury ich glaube The Masked Singer ist Edward Snowden what der Panda Wie Van de Maiklock jetzt, ja, ich wusste es doch! Ich hab Edward Snowden gesagt. Ich wusste es doch. Der Panda ist Edward Snowden. What? Der Panda... Amy van der Maiklog ist... Ja, ich wusste es doch!
Ich habe Edward Snowden gesagt.
Der Panda mit dem Sombrero
ist Edward Snowden. Der Panda mit
diesen Rasseln in der Hand und dem Sombrero-Hoot ist
Edward Snowden.
Und der Phönix ist Julian Assange.
What the...
Sat.1!
Sat.1, Leute! Was ist los?
Sat.1 macht einen Mega-Job. Stell dir vor, du fängst da irgendwie an als überambitionierter Redaktions-Guy und holst dann so die krassen Leute. Und das ist eine Staffel, wo nur Crazy Guy Oh, Bill Gates. Bill Gates war der Panther. Moment mal, Bin Laden? Ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich so dieses Argo-Ding. Dass das eigentlich nur eine Fake-Sendung ist, um diese ganzen Leute aus ihrem Land rauszuholen als Masked Singers, weil die dürfen ja auch privat nicht ihre Maske abnehmen.
Erdogan? Erdogan ist die Banane gewesen die ganze Zeit? Das glaube ich ja nicht. Was, das kann nicht wahr sein.
Wir haben ja diesen neuen Redaktionspraktikanten, stell mal.
Ja, irgendwie, der kriegt die Leute einfach so, ich ruf mal an, der Paar Benedikt, ich ruf mal Augustinus an. Kein Problem. Tim Cook, Tim Cook ist die Raupe. Aber das ist so, ja, kann auch sein, das kann jeder sein. Die wurden halt noch nicht angerufen, obwohl ich jetzt war, denn ich hab meiner Mom zum Geburtstag Karten geschenkt
für Let's Dance.
Okay. Und ich war jetzt mit ihr.
Für eine der Sendungen. Genau.
Letzte Woche Freitag war ich bei ihr.
Ach cool.
Sie war ganz aufgeregt, ist nach Köln gekommen.
Wir sind abends dahin gefahren, hatten eine tolle Zeit
in Köln-Ossendorf in den Studios,
wo wir immer waren für den Comedypreis.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du noch erinnerst, an die Räumlichkeiten.umlichkeiten. Und dann waren wir da. Und es ist halt eine super lange Show. So lang, dass man als Publikum im vierten Werbeblock Wasser bekommt. So Wasserflaschen werden umgereicht. Da hattest du einmal der Schlauch übers Publikum, damit die nicht austrocknen. Es hat so was Panic Room macht es, aber es war sehr geil. Und so Wahnfesten oder sowas. Und ich habe das Studio als relativ gross in Erinnerung aus dem Fernsehen und dachte mir, da wird schon nicht viel schief gehen. Wo sollen die uns hinsetzen? Man sieht bestimmt von überall gut alles cool. Und was gibt wahrscheinlich keine schlechten Plätze. Und dann hat meine Mutter gesagt, ja, irgendwie hat dann irgendwie, keiner mit ihrer Schwester gesprochen und so,
und die meinte, schrecklich, wenn man dann direkt hinter der Jury sitzt und die ganze Zeit im Bild ist.
Und dann haben wir so gelacht, haha, das wäre sehr lustig.
Und ich hätte so Family-and-Friends-Tickets über so Kontakte bekommen, weil man kriegt auch einfach keine Tickets, das war sehr, war ich sehr dankbar.
Und ich dachte mir, das sind wahrscheinlich eh die ganz letzten, hinterletzten Reihe Plätze.
Wo saßen wir? Direkt hinter der Jury. Also nicht direkt, direkt, aber so in der dritten Reihe hinter der Jury saßen wir. Moment, aber wann läuft die Folge? Nee, die lief jetzt. Das ist eine Live-Show, das ist das Spannende an dieser Show, deswegen habe ich mich auch sehr gefreut. Aber hat man nicht gesehen? Da hätte es ja bestimmt Tweets gegeben, oder? Nee, so präsent nicht, aber ich sehe mich die ganze Zeit. Wenn ich diese Show, ich habe dann danach bei RTL, kann man die irgendwie noch nachgucken und mach das mal. Ja, da will ich einen Reddit-Post mit allen Bildern, mit einem Screenshot. Ich bin so oft zu sehen, das ist insane, aber es ist so lustig, weil, und ich habe mich bestimmt, weiss ich nicht, eine Stunde lang kaputt gelacht, als ich mich da hingesetzt habe, weil sie wirklich mit dem Mindset reinkommt. Ja, also solange wir hinter der Jury sitzen, ist ja alles okay und wir sitzen direkt hinter der Jury, aber es gibt halt zwei Kameras auf der Jury, die eine ist so eine Single, die halt immer nur die Leute, die gerade sprechen drin hat und das andere ist so eine totale, da sind wir dann immer zu sehen. Schaut mal, vielleicht entdeckt ihr mich und meine Mom, die sehr euphorisch alles beklatschen und Baron meint, da gibt es einen Warm-Upper, man ist da hochgeputscht.
Ja klar, natürlich,
du gibst da ja alles.
Jetzt nimmt nicht jede Geste von mir auseinander.
Man ist da auch nicht man selbst.
Man gibt sich selbst gewisserweise einer Geilberube ab.
Absolut, man muss da mitspielen. Ich bin da absolut dafür.
Man spielt da mit, ich war da so drin
und hab so beklatscht
alles. Viel
seht ihr mich die Hände vor den Mund nehmen und schreien. Ich bin. Ja, ich erinnere mich, als wir bei Stephen Colbert saßen und er meinte so, ihr macht die Stimmung für die Show, ihr macht die Stimmung, wenn ihr eine geile Stimmung macht, wird es eine geile Show, wir brauchen euch, wir sind darauf angewiesen, dass ihr eine geile Stimmung macht. Und da hatten alle Bock, und ich hatte auch Bock, alles an Energie zu geben für die Show, und das muss schon auch sein. Genau. Ist halt Stephen Colbert, aber es war trotzdem megacool. Das heisst, du hast da richtig Promis gesehen, oder was? Ja. Während das Brot tanzt, nee, wie gesagt, Steve Jobs tatsächlich war dabei, hat mitgetanzt. Stark. Nee, es war ein Star-Packed Ensemble. Es sind schon viele rausgeflogen, ehrlich gesagt. Ich kannte auch viele nicht, aber ein paar kannte man. Und deine Mutter kannte aber alle. Die konnte dir wahrscheinlich komplette Lore und alles. Wusstest du, dass der ... Sie kannte das, sie hatte was mit ihm. Sie wusste alles, sie wusste Bescheid und hat sich sehr gefreut. Es war cool. Es ist wirklich eine Show, die sind in den letzten Live-Shows, die ich wahnsinnig konzeptionell mag. Denn Promis bei einer Live-Show jede Woche dabei zuzugucken, wie sie etwas erlernen, was sie eigentlich nicht können, und da irgendwie ein Profi an die Seite gestellt bekommen, finde ich eine total fantastische Idee. Ich frage mich, warum gibt es das nur bei Tanzen, aber Dancing with the Stars ist so ein cooles Format und ich verstehe, warum es in jedem Land existiert. Kannst halt eine gute Show machen am Ende. Wenn du jetzt Tennis spielst oder so, dann ist es halt nicht so eine gute Show. Bei Tanzen singen halt vielleicht noch. Aber es ist so cool und die werden jede Woche besser und es ist auch so geil, weil so Leute, auch wie Knossi, der tanzt diese Woche mit, dieses Jahr mit, die irgendwann am Anfang kommen sie doch so ironisch da rein, aber irgendwann lassen sie dann diesen Ironie-Layer fallen, weil sie einfach wirklich Spaß daran entwickeln. Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Ich finde das irgendwie cool und mag das Format dafür sehr gern. Schade, dass es keine Liveband gibt, habe ich mir gedacht, weil es eine Tanzmusikshow war. Aber jetzt mal im Ernst, du erzählst das jetzt alles so euphorisch auch ein bisschen als Bewerbung fürs Format, oder? Ich habe lustigerweise mit Sophie Passmann drüber gesprochen, weil sie auch tanzt gerne. Und ich habe früher auch getanzt, ich habe früher ja auch mal mit einer Freundin ein, ja so, keine Ahnung, vom Abiball hat man das bei uns eigentlich gemacht, hat man so einen Tanzkurs gemacht. Ja, habe ich auch gemacht. Hast du auch gemacht? Ja. Ja, machst du auch mit. Du, Sophie und ich, einer Staffel Let's Dance, wir sind dabei.
In der Dreiertanzsituation. Ich bin halt viel zu wenig.
Die Pyramide. There's no way, dass sie mich nehmen würden.
Gar keine Chance, viel zu unbekannt.
Da muss ich noch ordentlich was leisten in meinem Leben.
Naja, du warst jetzt im Fernsehen bei Let's Dance schon,
so ist es kein großer Schritt mehr.
Ich glaub doch. Aber da wäre ich sofort dabei,
glaube ich, irgendwann. Ja, meldet euch,
liebe Redaktionen, und ihr könnt vielleicht
Stefan Tietzes Hüften schwingen sehen, es wäre auf jeden Fall
eine grosse Freude, und ansonsten seht ihr ihn
jetzt schon, ich bin sehr gespannt auf die Bilder.
Schaut mal rein, vielleicht findet ihr mich
da sitzen und euphorisch
die Punktzeilen der Jury beklatschen.
Schaut mal rein.
Schaut mal rein, und ansonsten wünsche ich euch eine schöne
Woche, haut rein, und viel Spaß,
passt auf euch auf, wir sehen uns nächste
Woche wieder, bis dahin, macht's gut, tschüss und wir haben am Abend nach Hause.